>> The global financial crisis that we're
experiencing requires that
political leaders and business leaders get
together and work out
solutions that are global, work out solutions
that will bring about
sustainable solutions to the crisis.
This framework is not enough.
This framework is not sufficient.
Citizens, ordinary citizens, must do a lot.
In fact, we say, we go back to Kennedy and
paraphrase Kennedy.
Ask not what leaders can do to bring about
an end to the global
economic crisis, but rather what you can do
as a citizen to bring about
change?
To bring about solutions to the crisis we're
facing as a globe?
What does this require?
It requires us to revisit the our values.
It requires us to say, what am I doing in
my business that will
contribute to the solution of the crisis as
opposed to increase and
enhance the crisis?
In particular, we must redefine what success
means.
What is success for a company?
What is success for a community? For a family?
And let's move away from the profit-driven
strategy but go to a triple
bottom line approach that says the impact
on society is important.
The impact on the environment is important.
As an individual consumer, what is the impact
I'm having on society?
As an individual citizen, what is the impact
I'm having on the
environment?
In other words, we must judge each other.
We must judge ourselves using a framework
and value system that says
society, environment, and profits.
If this can be done at a personal level, this
can be done by
individuals.
Individuals must reduce their levels of consumption.
What is your carbon consumption as an individual?
What kind of car do you drive?
In terms of consumption of fuel, in terms
of pollution, how energy
efficient is your system that you're using
in the house?
What kind of lighting system are you employing?
What kind of batteries are you using?
Are you recycling as an individual?
What have you done in the community to make
a difference as a person,
as a individual?
What are you doing in the school system to
promote education?
In other words, we are encouraging the individual
to become a change
agent.
We're encouraging the individual to understand
the nature of the global
financial crisis and then encouraging them
to respond at a personal
level and offer solutions.
And as we do this, we don't want the African
citizen to be a
second-class citizen.
We want the African citizen or a citizen from
the poor countries to do
the same by also becoming part of the solutions
to the issues around
the global financial crisis.
In particular, we want to drive entrepreneurship.
We want to move away from ever being a worker.
In other words as individuals ask ourselves
how many jobs have I
created as an individual?
How many companies have I created?
So we are saying it is incumbent upon every
citizen to become a player
in terms of driving the economy.
In terms of growing the economy and the growth
the economy itself is
not enough, it must be a shared economic growth
strategy.
And this is what is required of the individual.
This is what required of the citizen in every
country.
And also in doing this, we must encourage
more people to take positions
in public leadership, to take positions in
political leadership.
Most of our best minds are in the private
sector; most of our best
minds are academia; most of our best minds
are in journalism; most of
our best minds are the in NGO communities
and mediocre politics if we
do this, we are winning the future of our
globe.
We must find a way to encourage our superstars,
our high performers to
move into the public sector.
We must encourage more young global leaders,
more people come to Davos
to get into the public sector and become political
leaders.
This is a calling and it must be understood
at a personal level.
In addition to this, individual citizens must
move away from the
Maslow's hierarchy of needs as defined as
Maslow.
Maslow's hierarchy of needs starts with shelter,
food and ends up with
self-actualization.
That is the highest stage, where seeing that
is [INAUDIBLE]model.
We must modify it and say how can I go beyond
self?
How can I self-transcend and leave a legacy,
make a difference in the
lives of the people around me.
This is the challenge to the citizen; this
is the challenge to the
individual, to be able to say I have self-transcended,
I have gone
beyond self; I have left a legacy in my community,
have left a legacy
in the world.
I've made a dent to the universe.
This can be done.
We shall overcome if as individuals we step
up to the plate and be
counted.